peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
chers amis bonsoir il est impossible
impossible injuste et marbre que vous ne
soyez pas tenu au courant de
l'extraordinaire dira qu' au moment même
où je vous parle se réalise en sologne
au coeur même de la france
un miracle authentique une histoire
vraie que nous allons ce soir vérifiez
ans à cette histoire vraie pourtant on
est bien loin d'ici
la france il la met cette histoire c'est
ici qu'elle est née elle commence tout
simplement aussi simplement que vient au
monde le petit michel
il est le septième enfant de l'une des
3500 familles qui peuplent badine l'une
des 700 gros gap tonkinoise le ton
cannettans chacun c'est cela que l'un
des pays qui composent le vietnam le
vietnam n'étant que l'indochine qui
finalement n'est qu'un tout petit
morceau de l'asie
c'est dire que michel neyret rien dans
ce pays misérable
un homme est bien peu de chose un enfant
est encore moins pourtant il faut bien
qu'un étrange destin et choisi lé
septième enfant de cette misérable
famille puisque ce soir vous êtes
plusieurs millions qui avec moi allez
vivre son extraordinaire histoire
à cette époque abidine et dans tout le
temps aucun il est de coutume que chaque
famille donne à la france un soldat
généralement on ne choisit pas c'est du
moins ce qu'on nous a dit en fait il y
as peut-être une raison de choisir celui
là ou bien cet ordre et le chef de la
famille réfléchit peut-être longtemps
avant de sacrifier michel plutôt qu'un
de ses frères mais ces raisins s'il y en
a mais ne les connaissons pas michel ne
les connaîtra jamais en effet il est
déjà n'arrive lorsqu à 21 ans ils
s'inclinent respectueusement devant son
père mais son sac sur l'épaule et sans
dire tout le chagrin qui l'a de quitter
sa famille s'en va il s'en va sans
casernés le voilà donc soldats le voilà
donc tirailleurs tonkinois mais
voyez-vous s'il est honnête et courageux
s'il est loyal et brave michel n'est
tout de même pas un vrai soldat du corps
gas avec des yeux qui se mouillent
jamais ce ne sera jamais un vrai soldat
parce qu'il n'a pas choisi bull est et
s'il porte un fusil silence des grenades
par contre lorsqu'il a du temps à lui il
s'amuse à dessiner et voilà ce qu'il
décide
car michel et croyant et chrétiens et
ses dessins tout change rigoureusement
authentique exprime une foi profonde
naïve je dirais presque
une fois minutieuse scrupuleuses
en 1939
même où il va déclencher le sac et le
fusil de son épaule et le jeter dans les
placards poussiéreux de la caserne au
moment où il s'apprête à retourner dans
sa rizière planté le riz près de sa
maison à ce moment même la france
mobilise
désormais pour toujours il ne poussera
plus que des gens et des herbes folles
grouillante de sangsues dans l'eau de sa
rizière on
non
vincent précieux rouge et 7 ans
croupissante
mais pensez vous ce sort ce destin pour
être lamentable n'en est pas moins
commun il y a des centaines de millions
de gens qui ont vu comme michel quinze
années de leur vie réduite à rien 15
années placé entre parenthèses
eh bien non si nous vous racontons ce
soir la vie de cet homme c'est parce
qu'elle est bien plus étrange encore
comme vous allez le voir
il fait toutes les guerres jusqu'à cette
affreuse jour de 1945 ou dans un hôpital
d'alger
on lui coupe les pieds on lui coupe
d'abord
le voilà donc 100 pieds tout le monde a
l'air de trouver cela naturel comme s'il
les avait perdus usées en parcourant la
moitié du monde de baby alger ce n'est
pas le résultat d'une bataille ce n'est
pas un objet baïonnette puisque ce n'est
pas un vrai soldat non il a beau être
courageux loyal et brave il n'attrape
que cette gangrène orange qui lui ronge
les jambes une gangrène venu on ne sait
d'où qui s'acharne sur lui sans qu'on
sache pourquoi
et quelques semaines plus tard on lui
coupe les mollets
et puis on coupe les genoux et puis on
recoupe pas encore
et puis encore jusqu'à ce qu'il ne reste
plus rien ni de ses cuisses mills et
jeunes jusqu'à ce qui est redevenu un
cul-de-jatte un homme tronc un tronc
dame
mais le destin
on n'ose pas dire les hommes
avait décidé de le frapper aussi d'une
autre manière il fallait l'amputer
encore l'amputer plus atrocement
[Musique]
un jour les lettres de sa femme qui
était son seul soutien 16 brusquement et
les lettres de son père c est aussi il
ne sait plus rien il ne sait plus qu'une
chose c'est que la guerre qui vient déjà
de dévorer la moitié du monde qui a tout
brûlé toute erreur et un peu partout
dans le monde a trouvé une nouvelle
pâture un nouveau gibier un nouveau
troupeau un pétard dans la foule des
petits hommes jaunes qui peuplent les
rizières la logique et dans sa rizière
sa rizière
à lui dans cette eau croupissante ou ne
poussait plus que des gens ne vivaient
plus que 2,7 pendant sa rizière donc le
sens de la famille à coups
[Musique]
et
étant donné ce que je vais être obligé
de vous dire maintenant il est
nécessaire de bien vous pénétrez de la
véracité de toute cette histoire elle
raille jusque dans ses moindres étals et
bientôt vous avez la vivre sur les lieux
mêmes où elle se poursuit au moment même
où je vous parle sans jambes
michel commence une grande promenade à
travers la france
le lian li l'ambulance en ambulance
jusqu'au jour de sa démobilisation
ce jour là il est à lyon soit dans un
hôpital
ce soit dans un hospice son essai pas
car il ne connaît plus bien entendu tous
les hôpitaux et les auspices les murs
blancs mais blouses blanches les liants
tube blanc mais carrelage blanc il ne
sait même plus qu'il existe d'autres
couleurs que le blanc
si ce n'est dans ses dessins où jésus
fini par avoir la peau bleue et la
vierge des cheveux rouges
ce jour là donc on le démobilise ou si
vous préférez c'est ce jour là qu'on lui
dit en lui glissant un petit quelque
chose dans la main au revoir et merci
depuis ce jour il est libre de rentrer
chez lui libre de retrouver sa rizière
en gros ça y est libre d'y être tué à
son tour
car s'il retourne dans son pays
ce ne sera que pour y mourir ho chi minh
à cette époque n'aime pas beaucoup les
soldats français de quelques couleurs
que soit leur bord sous l'uniforme
voilà pourquoi depuis ce jour michel qui
avait confiance qui avait souffert
consciencieusement qui avait perdu ses
jambes avec confiance avec conscience
michel n'aura plus pour regarder ceux
qui l'entourent qu'un regard affolé
d'animal trail trahi par tout le monde
mais pensez vous il y à la pension ce
petit quelque chose qu'on lui a glissé
dans la main c'est vrai il y a ce papier
là peut-être de lisez-vous mal mais même
si vous les lisez correctement
vous ne pouvez pas le comprendre vous ne
pouvez pas comprendre comment un jour un
homme a pu écrire
écoutez moi bien je soussigné maire de
la commune de fréjus certifie que
monsieur michel london gagne résidant à
fréjus l'hôpital militaire est titulaire
d'une pension militaire selon la loi du
18 juin 1919 d'un montant annuel de 27
mille cinq cents francs je dis bien d'un
montant annuel de 27 mille cinq cents
fois je soussigné qu'il est vivant qu'il
ne peut signer et qu'il est dans
l'impossibilité temporaire de se
déplacer pour cause de maladie on ne
peut pas comprendre ça
ça ne s'explique que par le règlement je
voulais déjà michel n'est pas un vrai
soldat ce n'est en somme qu'un rappeler
à ses jambes sont bien de vrais gens
mais aux yeux de l'administration
ce n'est pas un vrai soldat vrai
militaire de carrière
ce n'est qu'à tonkinois qui a fait un
service militaire de quatorze années et
dans ce cas il n'a le droit qu'à la
pension que l'on touche au tonkin à ce
moment c'est à dire 27 1500 francs par
an ce de la faute de personnes dont
beaucoup de pays du monde c'est comme
cela surtout dans les vieux pays bien
organisé
c'est une preuve de plus de la
feignantise des règlements qui lorsqu'on
les combis lorsqu'on les entremêle
lorsqu'on leur demande un travail
supplémentaire
finalement vous laisse tomber vous
trahissent et donne moins de bris à la
chaire humaine qu'à la viande de boeuf
non ça ne peut pas continuer comme ça
c'est ce que vous pensez en ce moment ça
ne peut pas continuer comme ça et bien
détrompez vous ça n'a pas de limite dans
le malheur on peut toujours aller plus
loin et c'est justement ce qui arrive à
michel mais alors pensez vous ou veut-il
en venir
et bien mes chers amis pour le savoir je
vous demande encore quelques secondes de
patience
a lyon michel prend pension dans un
établissement tenu par des frères il a
quelques 100 ou 150 mille francs
d'économies et pendant quelques mois il
vit si l'on peut dire qu'il vit car ce
n'est pas une vie le si vous voulez
entrer dans cette maison vous iriez tout
droit sonné à la porte
lui ne peut pas à cause des trois
marches que vous n'avez même pas
remarqué voici votre lit et vous avez
sommeil mais il y a trois pas à faire et
vous n'avez pas de jambes
voici pis encore vos yeux s'ouvrent
vous voyez le plafond dans la pénombre à
travers la forme des volets le jour
passent mais vous n'avez pas de jambes
si l'on vous oubliez vous resteriez dans
ce lit jusqu'au soir
jusqu'à mourir de faim ou jusqu'à
apprendre à marcher sur les mains
c'est ce que fit michel il appris à
marcher sur les mains on peut être
serait-il encore temps de lui installer
de jambes artificielles
oui peut-être de toute façon on ne le
fait pas et bientôt il est trop tard
peu l'articulation qui lui restent
soudés par l'inaction ne fonctionne plus
enfin après avoir promené michel sur une
petite voiture un quart d'heure par jour
le long des quais de la saône et pendant
des mois
un matin les frères se sont aperçus
qu'il n'avait plus d'argent
les 150 mille francs d'économies avaient
fondu en vérité il faut le croire
lorsque je vous dis qu'il n'y a rien à
reprocher à ses frères mais avec
beaucoup de précaution on demande aux
tons qui noir ce qu'il compte faire
on ne chasse pas lent on lui et ce même
à l'ondé nez on lui laisse tout le temps
nécessaire pour se retourner pour
décider de ce qu'il va faire
alors le pauvre michel fini ce jour-là
de perdre tout espoir enlève
par contre il n'en finira plus de se
demander ce qu'on attend de lui
sur quoi compte ton que veut ton qu'ils
passent sans jambes avec 27 1500 francs
par sinon un jour de promenade
se hisser par dessus le parapet de la
zone pour se noyer
une assistante sociale de l'armée
mademoiselle chaumette pendant un jour
connaissance de son dossier car michel
n'a pas de jambes mais il a un dossier
on peut même dire on peut presque dire
qu'il a échangé ses jambes contre son
dossier puisqu'on vit prenez les unes le
jour où l'on créé l'autre alors la jeune
femme bouleversée son petit dossier sous
le bras sans va frapper à toutes les
portes mais nulle part on ne veut de
michel nulle part il ya de place pour
lui
ici il faudrait de l'argent est là on ne
peut prendre un coup de jeune parce
qu'il ya trop de marches à monter et à
descendre
puis tout à fait par hasard mademoiselle
chaumette apprend qu'il existe au coeur
de la forêt solo niet dans le château
double est ce un centre de rééducation
des armée blindée que dirige à certains
commandants paix en appelant occupant le
commandant perret mademoiselle chaumette
ce sens abominablement mal à l'aise
michel à quelques pas d'elle
posé sur un canapé qui la regardent de
ses yeux noirs affolé lui se demande ce
que ça peut bien être ce centre double
sll se dit qu'il y a bien peu de chances
pour que l'on veuille de saint michel
c'est même le dernier endroit où l'on
puisse bien accepter un cul-de-jatte car
les pensionnaires du centre double s ont
toutes sortes de travaux
il travaille la terre le bois et même la
pierre lui at on dit
mais tous deux se taisent et attendent
un silence car ils savent bien que c'est
la dernière carte
hélas le commandant perret 3 fusent au
il est plein de bonne volonté il serait
même heureux de pouvoir soulager d'une
pareille détresse mais tout d'abord ses
pensionnaires bien que tous mutilés sont
astreints pourtant un travail manuel et
puis dans ce centre qui est pauvre où il
n'y a ni infirmière ni bonne soeur ni
femme de ménage au tout le monde
travaille dur
personne ne pourrait nourrir vêtir
promener et nettoyer un cul-de-jatte
voilà quelques semaines plus tard
mademoiselle chaumette rappelle à
nouveau le commandant bennett est la
preuve et michel dans un tel état de
désespoir de prestations qu'il faut bien
faire quelque chose les frères lui ont à
nouveau demandé ce qu'il comptait faire
et lui n'a su que pleurer
cette fois encore le commandant perret
doucement mais fermement refuse son
centre ne vit que de ses propres revenus
il lui est donc impossible d'engager les
frais considérables que nécessitent les
soins à donner à part rien faire il
refuse demoiselle a beau supplier il
refuse l avons presque pleuré au
téléphone il refuse alors elle se dirige
vers son lit et il prend une grande
couverture pour y rouler michel
c'est un soir
un soir de décembre ce château blanc
c'est le château double s oui cette
porte fini par s'ouvrir
et par est un homme au regard bleu qui
descend les marches jusqu'à la voiture
sur la banquette
le commandant perret doite un paquet
rouler dans une couverture qui remuait
faiblement alors le commandant parle qui
n'a jamais vu une semblable détresse
prend à bras le corps ce paquet sans
qu'il vit entre ses bras qu'il respire
et sans dire un mot
monte lentement les marches du château
le lendemain michel s'éveille et la peur
l'angoissé le désespoir au coeur grâce à
la petite voiture que lui a procuré
l'assistante sociale
s'en va découvrir le domaine double s
plus tôt ils cherchent à fuir les autres
pensionnaires qui le regardent passer
oui ces manchots c'est borgne s'est
unijambiste regarde pas c'est michel
avec pitié mais aussi presque avec
reproches et michel pan sera bientôt en
effet qu'il n'a pas sa place dans cet
étrange univers
car vous allez voir en effet mes chers
amis combien cet univers est étrange
d'abord pour gagner la forêt il doit
passer devant la ferme dans cette ferme
il ya des cochons des moutons des boeufs
et des vaches
ces cochons ce sont les infirmes les
mutiler les misères de toutes sortes
les alcooliques réfugiés où blaise qui
les élèvent les nourrissent enfin du
saucisson du jambon du lard du boudin et
de la saucisse en effet si michel ne le
découvre pas tout de suite
il vaut mieux que vous par contre vous
soyez au courant centre de rééducation
des armées blindés ce n'est qu'un mot
qui dissimule une prodigieuse expérience
en fait il entre n'importe qui au
domaine double s
il suffit de souffrir pour y être
accepté
donc les gens double s nourrissent des
cochons de même qu'ils élèvent leurs
vaches doivent le relais les abattent
les découpes et s'en nourrissent de même
pour les moutons la volaille et les
lapins
il n'est pas un morceau de viande à ou
blessent qu'ils ne soient produites par
la ferme
évidemment c'est la même chose pour les
légumes pour le beurre
et vous verrez que même le fromage
finalement de leur coûte rien attention
n'oubliez pas car dans un instinct vous
allez avoir tendance à le faire
n'oubliez pas que cette forêt au pénètre
michel en ce moment elle existe cette
arme existe
vous allez voir d'ailleurs que cet arbre
est vivant tandis que je vous parle et
que notre histoire se poursuit
aujourd'hui
fin novembre 1957
[Musique]
cette forêt autrefois envahi par les
ronces fut nettoyer ou de certains à
grands coups de faux à grands coups de
hache par les 101 firme mutilés ou
parias qui vivent dans la ferme double s
et ce sont eux qui ont planté ses
dizaines de milliers d'âmes ils ont
sélectionné eux mêmes les espèces
particulièrement apte à se reproduire
ici et depuis des années coupes et
plantes plantes et recoupe afin que
cette forêt produisent sens disparaît
c'est déjà un bel effort n'est ce pas
[Musique]
mais michel du haut de son affreuse
petit mais tu comprends qu'il n'a pas sa
place dans ce travail quotidien plus
loin derrière ses hauts murs fabrique
travail
les manchots les borgnes et les
misérables double s ce sont eux qui ont
élevé ces bâtiments austères et
l'immense charpente que l'on nous fait
voir composer toute entière de petites
planches entrecroisés c'est parce qu'il
n'avait pas de poutres et de solides que
les hommes doublet selon patiemment jour
après jour
clouté assemblée est monté comme un
fantastique jeu de mécano
[Musique]
avec le bois des arbres qu'ils abattent
il fabrique des tableaux de compteurs
pour l'aider ils en vendent pour cent
mille francs par jour environ
avec les déchets de bois il fabrique des
jouets
[Musique]
avec les déchets de jouer il fabrique
des caisses à camembert il échange ses
caisses contre des camemberts bien frais
mais dans cette passe tient dans cette
quotidienne activités que peut bien
faire un culte chante aussi lorsqu'il et
chemine le long de ce lac michel ne peut
en détacher ses yeux s'il l'était
croyant il laisserait sur le bord
l'affreuse petite voiture et serait bien
disparaître par dessous des lieux phares
d'ailleurs
je suis sûr qu'il y pense il s'en défend
mais il y pense
ils ne pensent même qu à ça
[Musique]
si vous tombiez dans ce lac
vous pourriez vous débattre pas lui cela
qui est artificiel
ce sont les mutiler les infirmes double
s les épileptiques les policiers les
tuberculeux les paludiers un doublet ce
qui en travaillant comme des fourmis ont
été levées ce bar ce petit pont en béton
il est petit mais ce sont des fourmis
malades qu'ils ont lancée par dessus la
rivière de même que ce sont eux qui ont
tracé la route qui mène à ce groupe de
maisons mystérieuse
ils ont tracé la route est tracée les
pierres mais au fait
pourquoi ce lac artificiel mais voyons
pour faire un paysage pour que la petite
ville qu'ils sont en train de construire
en plein désert de sologne
soit une petite ville jolie et
confortable car ce sont les infirmes
double s qui construisent cette petite
ville que michel parent combres et
découvre avec stupeur à sa droite ses
maisons en briques et en pierre de
taille en voie d'achèvement
ce sont des lilas ultramoderne les
futurs demeurent des pensionnaires
double s de ce côté ce grand corps de
bâtiment à colonnades prisonnier de ses
échafaudages est un futur hôtel de 50
chambres
les pensionnaires double s en eux-mêmes
couler le béton
des manchots et des unijambistes ont
couru dans ces échafaudages ont dressé
ses colonnades raboter ses parcs et
s'est laissé porter ses fenêtres dans
cet hôtel il est prévu ici une grande
salle de restaurant avec un bar à
dossier aux cuisines
dont vous distinguer les soubassements
tandis qu il ne manque plus entre ses
colonnes
que la grande verrière et les marches
monumental sous la magnifique terrasse
d'où l'on découvre le lac et l'admirable
paysage
alors michel dit dans le tourbillon de
cette activité se sentent plus inutiles
plus d 1 paraît que jamais il poursuit
son chemin cependant intrigué par cet
énorme bâtiment étrangers insolite sous
l'ensemble de cette ville il a fallu
bien entendu avant toute chose
construire à tout à l'égout ce fut un
travail peu spectaculaire un travail
interminables un travail désespérée des
mois et des mois d'efforts avant qu'une
seule pierre soit enfin poser quant à ce
bâtiment
c'est insolite bâtiment oui vous l'avez
deviné c'est un cinéma de 600 places
construit jusque dans ses moindres
détails par les pensionnaires double s
ils ont tous fait le grand balcon les
charpentes métalliques ils ont bâti
cette scène de car ils n'ont pas oublié
la fosse d'orchestre ni le trou du
souffleur ces petites plaques de bois
juxtaposer ignifuges et sont à résidus
de la syrie bref tout a été fait à
houleh sauf le velours des fauteuils
[Musique]
plus loin
au bord du lac ceci est une piscine avec
un grand bain un petit bain la piscine
est en plein air mais l'on sera
réchauffée
enfin voici la rue commerçante où sont
prévus une dizaine de boutiques com est
prévue tout au bout l'école car les
pensionnaires double less les uns après
les autres
fonde une famille il y a des enfants des
enfants qui vont à l'école à l'école
double est ce bien entendu mais revenons
à michel la nuit venue le commandant
perret tu entends battre la porte du rez
de chaussée c'est le vent qui la secoue
elle cogne régulièrement depuis une
demi-heure
or cette porte
il se souvient de l'avoir fermé et tout
le monde est couché dans le château tous
ces parents de séquelles pressentiment
il s'en va rejoindre la chambre de
michel elle est vide
alors
tandis que l'on lance du haut du perron
vers les quatre coins du domaine à
l'appel épouvanté michel michel on
visite toutes les pièces on ouvre toutes
les portes
les pensionnaires sa folie se ruent d'un
bout à l'autre du domaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfin commandant pb
aperçoit la petite voiture abandonnée au
bord de l'étang
tandis que quelques pas de la flotte une
chose étrange
c'est michel vietnamien que jack
il y va doucement comme un bouchon
l'atacama
[Applaudissements]
non michel n'est pas mort la preuve
c'est qu'il est là devant vous ce soir
mes chers amis je suis à côté de lui et
je vais bien entendu et poser les
questions que vous avez tous envie de
lui poser d'abord michel
je voudrais vous demander depuis combien
de temps vous êtes ici cela fait combien
de temps vous êtes arrivés en grèce s'il
vous plaît aidez van châu nova 1951 en
1958 et donc cela va faire six ans
bientôt que vous êtes ici michel si vous
êtes là devant de téléspectateurs ce
soir c'est que justement vous avez
réussi à vous adapter à cette vie
extraordinaire et je voudrais vous poser
une question que faites vous en blesse
quel est votre métier quel est votre
travail dans cette société qui produit
des socialement qu'est ce que vous
faites c'est mon métier comme olivier
mais à présent j'ai bien les femmes ne
peut pas faire des stages et salama 6e
place se fait un montage des tableaux
comme tenté deux fois sa holding
c'est ça vous faites votre métier de
menuisier vous étiez déjà menuisier
avant windows chine avant ce soit en
indochine vous étiez menuisier et vous
continuez
ici et vous assemblez des tas d'autres
moteurs pour l'aider fc ça vous fait en
quelque sorte le dernier travail le
fignolage mais sait déjà c'est déjà
formidable de faire ça michel je reste à
voir une autre chose depuis que vous
êtes ici grâce à l'ambiance double s
grâce à votre travail est ce que vous
avez réussi à oublier l'affront
cauchemar que je viens de raconter à
tous nos téléspectateurs puisque
maintenant vous êtes heureux comme on
peut définir ce mot en europe et un
avocat de debbie je venais si je vivais
grâce monsieur le combat ici à nous
presser au rallye j'ai donné un petit
peu travail je pouvais vivre
camara parce que je suis jeune je ne
sais pas où aller
je vis comme ça je compterai ça va bien
encore beaucoup de choses que je pouvais
parler parce que maintenant j'ai sorti
dans la paix j'étais invention c'est
très très bas vous toujours et avant je
sais alors je venais ici je demande au
grand dam et fo réclament mais pour moi
le nez je vivais maintenant ça va
et maintenant vous vivez oui maintenant
vous avez des démarrages et comme que
c'est la garde comme tout le monde vous
vivez comme tout le monde vous
réussissez à gagner votre vie et donc
c'est cela le grande solution c'est en
quelque sorte ce qui vous a permis de
vous intégrer à cette société nouvelle
qui nous blessent les voyez-vous michel
nous allons maintenant parler d'un d'un
autre personnage d'une autre personne
qui se trouve ici à côté de jeu dénommé
bien souvent dans votre histoire
c'est le patron en quelque sorte de
cette maison c'est le commandant père
est mon commandant si vous le permettez
je vais vous poser quelques questions
pour que nos téléspectateurs
est ce mieux ou blessent se rend mieux
compte de l'expérience extraordinaire
qui ai commencé ici depuis bientôt dix
ans tout d'abord mon commandant quelle
est l'idée maîtresse double s
question bien vaste en fait ce que vous
appelez l'expérience double s n'a
commencé véritablement qui a à peine
trois ans et demi au début dès que j'ai
eu à qui blesse
j'ai pensé simplement y organiser un
banal centres d'accueil dans lequel mes
camarades plus douloureusement touchés
par la guerre pourrait trouver des
conditions confortables un peu plus
confortable peut-être que dans les
centres traditionnels voeux dans lequel
leurs confrères si je peux dire sont
admis et puis à leur contact
en le voyant vivre ces garçons que je
croyais suivant une pensée assez commune
peu apte à vivre la vie sociale
pratiquement bonze à rien je me suis
aperçu qu'on pouvait découvrir et faire
naître chez eux des possibilités toutes
différentes et qu' il était possible
qu'il fallait faire d'eux des gens
normaux socialement normaux
économiquement bien entendu normaux mais
ayant un toit un métier une famille donc
cette idée mon commandant elle se
réalise actuellement
mais s'il est facile d'imaginer
l'expérience double s lorsqu'on veut le
château maintenant lorsqu'on voit les
maisons surgit du sol lorsqu'on voit
l'hôtel lorsqu'on voit le cinéma mais au
départ au départ nous le savons ce
château
c'était une bergerie des moutons coucher
dedans il ne servait plus à rien depuis
dix ans le parc c'était un taillis et à
l'endroit vous avez construit des
maisons à l'endroit où va naître cette
ville où elle n'est actuellement les
presque achevés n'est ce pas il n'y
avait que des des petits ruisseaux
serrés les uns contre les autres
un homme ne pouvait pas passer appelle
une bête je pus suppose donc que si
maintenant l'expérience que vous avez
tant d semble réalisable
au départ quand il n'y avait rien à mon
avis ça doit être une période de
découragement de suite de découragement
plus exactement un mois semblables
découragement le mot est trop fort parce
qu' il faudrait d'abord que souhaite un
sentiment auquel nous soyons auquel
peut-être jeu soit accessible et je ne
réalise pas très bien ce que c'est que
le découragement je dois dire il est
exact qu au début on m'a pris très
exactement pour un fou il faut appeler
les choses par leur nom
on m'a pris pour un utopique qu'on a eu
quelquefois plaisanté mon nom en disant
que perrette et le pot tollet était une
chose fort connue et puis il y avait
quelques raisons que l'on me traite de
tel étant donné qu' il faut bien dire
que les premiers essais les premiers
efforts ont été aurait pu s'inscrire
dans un western
nous étions effectivement dans une
nature absolument folle qu'il a fallu
tailler à coups de machette a tout faux
rentrer dans le dossier je vous arrête
autonome au départ évidemment vous avez
eu des spécialistes avec des architectes
qui nous ont aidés mais si nous avions
eu ça n'aurait pas été amusant si nous
avions eu tout ça nous n'avions
rigoureusement rien que notre volonté
notre bonne volonté mais surtout une
volonté une volonté farouche là
l'intention la volonté d'aboutir et de
faire ce que nous nous étions fixés
donc personne ne vous a donné un conseil
pour construire ces maisons pour dresser
les plans de cette ville non seulement
nous a pas donné de conseils mais je
dois dire en toute honnêteté qu'on nous
a donnée approximativement tous les
découragements possible on m'a fait
sentir en toute occasion que c'était une
utopie que c'était impossible et que
nous n'arriverons jamais à réaliser ce
que nous essayons maintenant de prouver
réalisable donc c'est vous seul avec les
mutilés qui sont ici qui avait construit
la ville que nous avons vu tout au long
de cette émission c'est nous seuls 2 et
moi qui avons tout fait tout conçu tout
réalisme et mon commandant une autre
question
d'où tirez-vous vous revenez très
exactement comment ça marche et d'une
manière commerciale si j'ose dire
j'aimerais bien quand on parle de
revenus ensemble fait état d'un capital
hors un capital nous n'en avons qu'un je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure de la
volonté
nous avons notre volonté nous avons
surtout notre travail
et c'est peut-être le facteur essentiel
il est intéressant de faire ressortir
avec des gens qui était considéré comme
incapable de tout que l'on pensait
seulement capable du pire que l'on
imaginait parce que physiologiquement
diminué incapable de faire un effort de
production valable de ces gens qui comme
je le répète fréquemment étaient
considérés comme des parasites méritant
uniquement d'être secourue et n'étant
pas capable d'autre chose
nous sommes arrivés à faire des
producteurs valable absolument capables
de concevoir de réaliser et de faire
leur prospérité en s'intégrant dans la
prospérité nationale dans la prospérité
humaine dans le cadre de la prospérité
générale
donc c'est en quelque sorte un travail
un circuit fermé on peut dire que
l'expérience double s se rapproche de la
société coopérative
oui c'est par leur travail que tout a
été fait mais il faut dire que nous
avons été aidés par un certain nombre de
d'esprit compréhensif très peu très peu
d'esprit compréhensif et en particulier
vous citiez tout à l'heure le michel
avec une parfaite modestie assez
inexacts d'ailleurs vous disiez que tout
était exact dans cette histoire il n'ya
peut-être qu'une partie de les pilotes
qui ne l'est pas c'est que michel est un
admirable ouvriers c'est non seulement
le charmant camarades d un gentil garçon
d'une modestie excessive mais c'est
devenu un ouvrier de haute qualité et
bien ceci n'a pu être fait que parce que
nous avons du travail
l'électricité de france dont michel
monde comme il ne vous disais tout à
l'heure des tableaux de conteur nous a
beaucoup aidés elle nous aide encore
beaucoup en nous donnant une un volume
considérable de commandes des grands ça
st nous avons vu par conséquent réalisé
la trésorerie indispensable à cette
espèce de petit état que nous avons
réalisés puisque au fond nous offrons
toutes les caractéristiques d'un état
vise vivant sur soi-même et les pouvoirs
publics mon commandant moussa lors dans
son ensemble une catastrophe dans son
ensemble parce que
l'administration voyez-vous est une
hydre as en tête c'est même ma placard à
mille tiroirs et dans ses tiroirs y en a
quelques-uns dans lequel on trouve des
choses bonnes j'évoque un préfet qui a
été un véritable ami de la maison qui a
été pour nous surtout dans des
conditions critiques
un véritable avocat un efficace avocat
et quand je dis avocat je dis bien en
connaissance de cause car il s'agissait
d'un procès qui mettait en cause de
l'existence
l'administration l'enregistrement pour
des sommes qui étaient relativement
minimes à côté des services considérable
que nous lui rendions avait décidé
purement et simplement de plus en vente
nous étions vont afficher vendable nous
devions et exécuter on devait faire
disparaître ou blessent l'histoire de la
poule aux oeufs d'or est une histoire
qui serait dit encore assez fréquemment
avec dans certains cas nous rapportions
pratiquement à l'état les dizaines de
millions que parents nous lie
économisons car je vous rappelle nous
n'avons pas un centime de subvention
nous n'avons jamais touché un centime de
subvention de l'état et l'enregistrement
pour les sommes encore une fois
infiniment inférieur à celle que tous
les ans nous évitons ou trésor des
dépenses et nous avait purement et
simplement par ministère lui s'y
afficher et van tu nous n'avons pas été
vendus nous avons obtenu les délais
nécessaires mais nous avons payé payé
avec notre travail payé avec top
ténacité payer avec toute la peine de
ses hommes douloureux qui ont travaillé
pour payer ce que l'étape on a pensé ne
pas pouvoir nos économies mon commandant
en quelque sorte une expérience qui se
poursuit ici et je sais qu'elle
continuera tant que vous aurez un
souffle de vie tant que vous pourrez
animer ce centre double s
je sais qu'ici on construira on essaiera
de nouvelles choses je sais que vous
avez envie bien des projets on va faire
ici une champignonnière parce que vous
avez la chance d'avoir retrouvé des deux
vieilles carrière qu'on peut aménager
je sais également que vous avez d'autres
projets sans que vous vivrez je sais
qu'ici sans arrêt vous recevrez d'autres
hommes qui sont au plus bas de l'échelle
et que grâce à votre procédez vous
arriverez à les amener au plus haut
doubs
mais voyez vous ce soir ce qui était le
plus dur à faire admettre au départ
c'est que cette histoire que nous venons
de raconter était vrai et mon commandant
il faut l'affirmer encore une fois la
tentative double s a réussi parce que
justement elle a toujours été une
histoire vraie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]